uh so yeah it's a pleasure to have our
next speaker Yash kanoria is also a
colleague from Columbia University uh at
the business school and uh
he's also apparently Amazon right now
and uh he will talk about Dynamic
special matchings today
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for the invitation to this wonderful
Workshop thank you all for coming uh
yeah so I'm on sabbatical uh so though
my home is Colombia right now I'm at
Amazon for a year and it's quite fun so
I'm doing supply chain optimization
there
somebody asked me what's a connection
are you using this in Amazon uh this is
a hard question
maybe some indirectly but uh this uh
this work actually so for me it's it's
uh it's uh close to my heart it goes
back to things that I've been working on
in some form for more than a decade uh
not continuously but in some form it has
been sort of gestating for a long time
so I'm excited to share where we've
gotten with this
this is work with my esteemed co-authors
uh Elon Chan was a postdoc with me and
he just started as a faculty member at
cuh case engine akshit Kumar is a PhD
student at Columbia so he's a main
person driving this agenda forward and
Omar best base is a colleague at
Columbia
so um there's a number of applications
that motivate this type of study one set
of uh so one one sort of whole bunch of
inspiration is coming from ride healing
you can think of this as Dynamic
matching in typically two-dimensional
space and the supply and demand both
live in this two-dimensional space they
will come online uh Dynamo both sides
come online dynamically they are matched
they go off and do their thing next set
of demand and Supply come in so this is
sort of dynamic on both sides uh you
have a number of other matching
platforms that also serve as inspiration
uh here you can think maybe the supply
is coming in beforehand it's more of a
sort of static thing and the demand
comes in dynamically and needs to be
matched the space here so if you think
of a lodging kind of setting uh the
space for the supply units might
correspond to their location so the size
to the amenities the price and so on so
there are dimensions for each of these
different attributes and the demand has
also the demand units are these
customers they also have preferences
over these different attributes so they
also live in a a space with the same
number of Dimensions okay so we will
talk about a model later which will be
inspired particularly by these types of
matching platforms
Airbnb and upwork uh kind of platforms
and I come from operations so Network
Revenue management is this this whole
set of problems and traditionally we've
been thinking about models where there
is a certain small number of Supply
types and or resources and a small
number of demand types and we let the
number of customers uh scale up but keep
those number of types small uh
increasingly this may not be a good
model of things that are actually going
on so now I'm at Amazon and our
customers are in tens of thousands of
different zip codes they may have other
dimensions of hydrogen 80 as well so you
have many many types and you want to be
able to say something about how to do
your how to make your decisions in in
that type of situation as well
okay so at a high level the there are
going to be two kinds of questions so
one is how large uh are the costs that
you have to bear uh that arise due to
the spatial heterogeneity right and
demand uh and Supply as well as the
uncertainty about the future that is
inherent when you have to match
dynamically
static matching we know how to solve
right but Dynamic matching you you kind
of you you have some forecast about the
future but you don't know exactly what's
going to come in and it's also an
algorithmic challenge
okay so that brings us uh to this uh the
second main question which is how to do
the matching uh in a in a dynamic
setting
so we are going to focus on scaling
behavior of this matching cost it will
be related to matching distance uh we
are going to look at the scaling
Behavior with the market thickness as a
function of the dimension B
and I will not be concerned with
constant factors and so on for the
theoretical results
this was just at a very high level so
I'm going to be talking about uh
basically these these three pieces of
work uh uh sort of high level
differentiator of this first paper that
I'll talk about is that it's it's a it's
supposed to set some theoretical
Foundation
and we're going to assume that the
demand and Supply spatial distributions
are the same okay so the only thing
bothering us will be the spatial
stochasticity
and this is where the costs are going to
arise from as well okay it's going to be
less of an algorithmic question though
there is there is some algorithm that
I'll need to use to be able to get
positive results but it's more about
just quantifying this these costs that
arise as a function of the nature of the
Dynamics and the number of dimensions
foreign
we have a couple more pieces of work
which are getting closer to to specific
application domains where in particular
we will allow the distributions the
spatial distributions of demand and
Supply to be different from each other
you can try to model certain aspects of
applications first we'll talk about
matching platforms the other one is
going to come from revenue management
so let's dive into the first
paper here
and by the way I haven't put a huge
amount of material so please interrupt
me we can have a discussion and I'll
take questions throughout the talk
it's a sort of gentle warm-up we are
going to have supply and demand located
uh in the unit hypercube in D dimensions
and we are going to assume that these
are coming from a uniform distribution
and in particular we notice that this
distribution is same for supply and
demand right
we are going to try to minimize the cost
which is the expected average match
distance
let's let's think of it as the euclidean
distance any minkowski distance is going
to behave the same because we won't care
about constant papers you can use
uniform distribution assumption is easy
to generalize but right now we are
assuming that the two distributions are
the same
okay so we just had lunch so now let's
uh let me throw a riddle your way
yes yes
all right
yeah we are going to have online models
but this warm up right now the first
vaccine has still will be aesthetic
person yeah but but the interest is in
uh Dynamic models the static modules
early 90s and there are some classic
places
yeah
so the question is the following
right I have n Supply units located IID
uniformly in let's say two dimensional
space right in this two dimensional
square and I I don't reveal the location
of that Supply I just say hey here here
is a demand unit
what is the expected distance
of the nearest supply unit to this
demand unit
and in particular what is the scaling of
this nearest supply unit with n
hey is it 1 upon n is it 1 upon N
squared
One D is one upon n good
yeah perfect so uh good so the answer uh
Sanjay got it right it's 1 upon square
root n
okay yeah because it's just special
it has to be worse
[Music]
it has to be larger than one upon n is
that now we are asking for proximity
along two Dimensions not just one
dimension and in particular it's one
upon square root n one way to see it is
that if I have a ball with a radius one
upon square root and the volume of that
ball in the surface area here is 1 upon
n
and that's the volume that I need in
order to have order one points because
the density is n
so in 2D is 1 upon the square root of n
in D Dimensions by analogy it is 1 upon
the DX root of n
okay we cannot do better than the
nearest neighbor the nearest our
neighbor uh uh for in terms of our match
cost but when we are matching
we actually might have some conflicts
right so these two uh demand units here
they both have the same nearest neighbor
but they cannot both be matched to the
same nearest neighbor so the match cost
might actually be larger than the
nearest neighborhood
and this Gap is actually potent even in
a scaling sense
in one dimension
the
minimum cost the minimum cost matching
actually has a 1 by square root and
distance whereas the nearest neighbor is
order one upon n okay
the reason for this is if you take the
left half of the unit interval uh it
will have a stochastic excess or
shortfall of square root end points
right so I have to go square root and
points away to find the match part
so this causes this distance to blow up
by a factor square root and
okay so this is this is one reason that
this nearest neighbor distance may not
be achievable in this case it's not but
we will think of this as one very simple
uh sort of Benchmark to keep in mind and
we will compare what we can achieve with
this nearest neighbor distance okay so
this is why I've introduced this
quantity there is one more complication
because we will have Dynamic models of
magic this complication is that we have
uncertainty about the future right so
this demand comes in let's say the
demands are coming in one at a time and
you have to match them immediately
that supply unit will go away and cannot
be used for future demand units right so
these are my Supply units right now so
who should I match this demand unit to
in particular would you prefer a or b
so my access demand unit
there's a few more to come
yeah so so this is
uh so my transitions are not or maybe
the circle is just not visible but a is
closer than b so the greedy algorithm
would have picked it but maybe I want to
preserve a way for future because I
might have some demand which comes on in
the left bottom left corner and it'll be
much better of saving it to match with
that demand unit it means I might match
with B right now
okay so there's that's a reason that I
may not even be able to get down to the
static matching cost
and it's also leading to an algorithmic
question of how to do the matching look
at that algorithmic question is going to
be a little bit in the background for
the first part of the talk but it is
that
okay so we are going to have uh so this
is supposed to sort of set up some
foundations right this this initial
model it's not meant to be applied it's
meant to set up a theoretical foundation
so this uh paper considers three models
all of them have some commonality the
supply and demand live uh in the D
dimensional unit hypercube they are IID
uniform uh the cost is always going to
be the expected average match distance
they're going to differ basically in the
nature of the Dynamics we want to see
how the Dynamics actually affects us the
first model is going to be just a slight
extension of the work going back to the
80s and 90s where we are just looking at
the static matching cost in space okay
so we will have n demand units and N
plus M Supply units this excess Supply M
greater than zero is where we have an
extension over the previous work it will
tell us how much does this matching cost
actually matching constraint bother us
right to what extent are we able to get
close to the nearest neighbor distance
or not if we don't have any uncertainty
about the future
the second model will have demand coming
in dynamically but the supply will be
there beforehand
in all other ways it's identical to the
static model so now we'll get a sense
from this uh to what extent does
uncertainty about the future make US
income more cost
okay what's the best cost achievable
here and the third model will have both
sides coming dynamically
and subject to that it's going to be the
simplest model that I could think of so
that simplest model will have at any
point in time little lamb Supply units
around in the system and at every time
one demand unit will come you need to
choose whom to match it with they leave
an N1 supply unit will come at some
independent uniformly random location
okay so I call that the fully Dynamic
model
okay so now the next
uh part of my top I'll just be telling
you what are the results that we get for
each of these models
so just to summarize to give you a
preview of what I find so this this
matching cost right
it has to be at least the nearest
neighbor distance this is not math by
the way this is some cartoon uh it has
to be at least a nearest neighbor
distance question as to what extent does
it become larger because of the matching
constraint the answer we find is it's
small except in one case
and to what extent does it become larger
because of the cost of uncertainty about
the future and we find that is it's
small in all cases
you can buy small here I mean something
specific it doesn't change the scaling
Behavior with the market thickness
so these uh this n and M
uh and in this case a little Little Neck
okay so some some thickness parameters
there's a cost of green be also small or
yet the algorithm that I will show this
for is a variant of VD that I am able to
analyze
uh there will be a case where we have a
logarithmic Gap there's one creation
which is a log Factor there what are the
cases it's a constant Factor there I
think that the upper bond is loose and
you need a small sophisticated algorithm
than 3D to uh to close that Gap
is enough
okay so here's another quick summary of
of the results so on the left we have
the static and semi-dynamic models so
one nice thing is that they are in the
same column okay so that's semi Dynamic
model the uncertainty about the future
doesn't bother us so the results are the
same uh for one dimension that nearest
neighbor distance is not achievable we
already got a preview of that in the
static magic right uh just in the in the
initial warm-up so that's not achievable
but everywhere else you can actually get
down to the nearest neighbor distance up
to a log square root log factor in two
Dimensions up to a constant factor in
higher Dimensions this fully Dynamic
model where both sides are coming in
online uh we can actually get down to
the nearest neighbor distance even in
one dimension so this is something cool
to look forward to uh why is this the
case right
why does this 1D case not bother us and
this actually looks like the 2D case
here in a certain sense okay the uh sort
of Applied inside that one can try to
derive is where is excess Supply helpful
to you now if you have already gotten
down to the nearest neighbor distance
even a linear excess is only going to
give you a constant Factor Improvement
in the nearest neighbor distance so you
don't really need excess Supply if you
want to you can't improve the scaling
Behavior okay so excess Supply doesn't
help but in the 1D case because I'm
actually incurring across much larger
than the nearest neighbor distance
exercise Supply can help me get the cost
down
and this is the phenomenon that is
helping us here is that uh excess Supply
helps to smooth out fluctuations
stochastic fluctuations in the quantity
of demand at larger length scales
it's not that it's bringing the nearest
neighbor closer it's moving out that
left half of the interval the total
amount of demand will not exceed the
supply and that is that is the source of
the benefit
in the fully Dynamic model uh there is a
more sort of a a mundane kind of
phenomenon there a pedestrian phenomenon
which is that if I have more Supply
units just hanging around then obviously
the nearest neighbor distance comes down
and I can get close to that new nearest
neighbor distance so excess Supply helps
you already say how M relates to act
like it is
like the excess Supply
yeah so the the first two models are
capital M if some arbitrary non-negative
thing which is sub-linear it shouldn't
be more than linear and
it shouldn't be more than a multiple of
capital N but it can be any scaling
capital
but like not a constant it has to go to
Infinity no it can be zero I mean
yeah
and that's uh the last one that is the
scaling parameter the Little M is the
scaling parameter the The Horizon shows
up in a secondary way so I'm kind of
hiding that think of it as what is the
steady state cost
so you need some minimum Horizon for the
results
both sides
so am I there let's say I initialize the
model with them at IIT uniform location
and then a demand unit comes and then
you have to choose one of the supply
units to match it to and then they leave
and then a supply unit comes so again
I'm sort of back I'm back to having M
Supply on the female system and this
keeps repeating
description
ah so you're saying I should I
um
okay so I will uh I will let's talk more
about this offline but I very
specifically will use a spatial
structure right I mean if you want to
ignore you should do greedy I mean at
least you should do something greedy
like if you just start matching is it
like because you can get
money
like tight space is already continuous
right it's not even clear
like what's the formulation to apply an
online
let's talk more about this offline see
my comment is that this the using the
spatial geography is very Central to
understanding the calls and getting near
optimal costs
so somehow like he's using some black
box thing I am very doubtful that it can
be helpful here
okay well let's talk more about
questions
yeah
so I could have done that but that could
have made my life harder so somebody
else
yeah so this is taking me away from
whatever is interested in so I I just
completely assumed it away in the way I
set up the model itself there's always
is at each time you have one uh supplier
one thing yeah yeah so two people are
ever yeah yeah so that is by design of
the model
you can study other model but like you
do it yeah
[Music]
so just yeah it should work I mean the
theorem will come up I mean I will leave
it bigger
I catch it right so what you're saying
is the red thing Delta and we are not
achievable once you have n you can
achieve it
that's what you're saying right once you
have excess Supply and capital and
management it's like so you need linear
excess if you want to get down to this
scale you need linear so if you have
more than square root you can start
improving upon the case without excess
and I mean you can you will get one upon
the excess as the thing you achieve okay
so we have a few
uh
there's going to be there for excess you
will get down to one upon capital M
M
so you said that it reduces
fundamental okay this whole uh okay uh
we will come to this this is uh there is
some asterisk to even
say what is Delta and we are in that
setting so just give it just hold on for
a second
yeah I think for this audience is too
much in production because it should be
more comprehensive
okay so we are
there's a very rich set of papers from
the 80s and early 90s on static uh
spatial random spatial matching uh which
is which is certainly serving as a
foundation here uh in terms of online
algorithms Shores thesis actually has
some gems uh and and uh that served as a
big inspiration online build package uh
also special matching and stuff from
there uh
uh recently there has been a a bunch of
papers inspired by ride healing which
says I need to maintain some excess
Supply okay we learn as one of those
papers uh I need to maintain some excess
Supply so that when a customer comes in
there is some car in the vicinity that
is perfect and I don't have to match
them to the somebody at the other end of
town uh these are basically some reduce
forms uh style model where they don't
actually model the details of matching
and how the state changes and all of
this uh this paper uh slightly slightly
Village the one I'm presenting and they
study the one-dimensional semi-dynamic
model
I will be specific about what is that
they found in that case it says Supply
but that's the only case for excess
Supply help so we have to be careful in
interpreting that things
okay so now let's let's dive into the
models and results the first two we are
going to have the same result okay so
the first one is the static model and we
will see what's the enroll of the magic
Ministry excess Supply
to the model again uh I think by now we
are quite familiar with the model so n
plus M demand units or Supply units and
demand units everything is present
beforehand
and I just want to quantify what is the
uh the minimum cost achievable
it is not an algorithmic challenge like
I know how to do magic right efficiently
question is what is this minimum cost
achievable how does it scale with nnm
okay
so these are all things known beforehand
uh this is for the case where there's no
excess Supply
okay so folks work very hard especially
for the 2D case for three and higher
Dimensions telegram has a much sharper
thing than what I'm showing here he's
he's characterizing it uh quite closely
I think the thing to note here uh the
thing I want you to take away is that
for two and higher Dimensions you're
getting down to the nearest neighbor
distance uh barring the square root log
n factor in the 2D case okay that one is
somehow the most interesting and we'll
see why later in the top but
mathematically it's sort of the most
delicate uh the 1D case you do not get
down to the nearest neighbor distance is
almost as bad as a 2d case
okay so my first job was to extend this
to the case of Excess Supply
so theoretically not the the hardest
thing to do but uh I was able to to get
this extension uh which basically says
that in the 1D case if I have the excess
Supply uh Beyond square root N I
actually get the benefit and the cost
goes down
and eventually it's down to the nearest
neighbor distance if I have linear
excess Supply
the point is that you can get down to
the nearest neighbor distance and higher
dimensions
uh okay so we are going out of order but
yes
it's in higher Dimensions the surface
area is of a ball is quite large
uh I mean as the radius of the ball
grows the surface area grows faster than
the square root of the volume okay so so
and in two days uh it's the boundary
case where it grows at the same rate and
that's where things get more complex
okay so that's really what
differentiates the lesson two
six
foreign
Supply helps you overcome that
okay now we want to understand the role
of uncertainty about the future when you
have Dynamic arrivals of only the demand
side okay so that is a semi Dynamic
model
the only change from the static model is
the demand units
the demand units come in sequentially
and they must be matched immediately
upon arrival
which only makes our problem harder
okay we need to be careful on how to
match as well even in order to get the
positive results on the cost scaling
okay this theorem should look familiar
not because you read it but it's just
visually exactly the same it's only now
it's a theorem about the the new model
okay so the content is in the upper
bound and we are getting exactly the
same upper bounds apart from constant
factors yeah
so the bottom line is that you have to
pay only at most a constant Factor
inflation and cost uh to even though you
have uncertainty about the future here
compared to the static model
yes
so there is a algorithm which enables us
to prove this stuff uh except for D
equal to two we are using a variant on
greedy for D equal to 2 this will lead
you to have a root log n Gap so we use
some other we we sort of use an existing
algorithm from uh Holden Perez inside
it's called gravitational matching but I
think so this is come up with a few
different ways of proving this upper
bound but none of them is greedy you
cannot use greed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh with no excess Supply it's obvious
that you will have at least a one by
square root n cost right that's true
even for the static problem and uh there
was this this paper which had just come
out or where they so akbarpur uh Ali
muhammadi Lee and saberi so what they
showed is that with linear excess Supply
you can bring this cost down to Atmos
log Cube then upon n
and this is what uh Eric and co-auth has
actually improved to one opponent last
week
okay but uh so so what we showed is that
you can actually get tight upper and
lower bounds uh for this one dimensional
case uh as a function of M okay so
visual representation of the theorem I
just showed you okay after at a certain
point excess Supply actually helped you
bring the cost down all the way to the
nearest neighbor distance
and then uh two and higher Dimensions as
well we have tight bonds basically the
nearest neighbor distance for all of
these cases wearing some square root log
Factor
because as I have more Dimensions my
cost does go up because I am looking for
proximity along more dimensions
right so for any fixed mm I have a sort
of SD grows I do have to income more
costs
1D is the only case where I start at a
point which is much above the nearest
neighbor distance and exercise Supply is
needed to come down in all other cases I
don't actually benefit from excess
Supply I'm already at a low cost
this third model this was uh technically
like uh pretty challenging uh so this is
where both sides are going to come in
dynamically uh and we will see a
remarkable phenomenon right uh somehow
that 1D aberration is going to go away
okay we will not now have this aberrant
Case by different where you have a much
larger cost in one dimension than the uh
the nearest neighbor distance that comes
up
okay so this uh again our uh our model
uh has the same spatial distributions uh
this time we are going to maintain
Little M Supply units in the system at
any time by definition of the model uh
and the these challenge is going to be
that when I match a supply unit that
supply unit disappears and the new
supply unit comes at a uniformly random
location but my state is not miid
uniformly located supplies because
what's left is a function of how I was
doing the matching in the past so this
distribution can get skewed and this can
inflate my costs going forward
so what is the meaning of nearest
neighbor distance here because I don't
even have a handle on the state I mean
that's the thing I struggle to to do and
and to prove things right but we are
going to just take an optimistic nearest
neighbor distance so I give you the
superpower that you can reposition all
Supply units at every period before you
see where the demand unit is coming in
so maybe you'll put it at evenly spaced
location or some some even smarter
version than that and how far apart will
they be that grid will have this
granularity which is 1 upon the dth root
of Little M so certainly I cannot do
better than this how close can I get to
this that's the question
okay
the first result is that in one
dimension you can't get down to one upon
m in fact you can't get down below log M
upon m
this actually is by reduction to the two
dimensional uh spatial
static matching problem
because we start getting a sense that
somehow this time is acting like an
additional spatial dimension
right so we have a lower bound but
there's only a log M gap between that
and the nearest neighbor distance is it
tight the question is still open but you
can actually achieve log squared M upon
m
I have shown that there's an algorithm
which gives you almost the nearest
neighbor distance in one dimension for
long enough Horizon right okay so let's
not focus on this uh this little thing
now for D two and higher you can get
down to that optimistic nearest neighbor
distance to within a constant Factor
okay so somehow the D dimensional case
in this fully Dynamic model is acting
like the D plus one dimensional case in
the static model
okay I won't go too much deeper into
this but time gives us we can do some
averaging over time now in this
situation where both supply and demand
are coming in dynamic
do you think
is the right answer uh
it shouldn't be obvious to you at this
point but I I don't think it should be
but yes uh I think this is the right
answer and I don't really cannot get
this like I'm sure maybe cannot get this
but I think really if you log into this
we have
absolutely log n Square where I think
there's a different algorithm which
should come from some of Swords build
packing ideas it manages different
length scales and I'll also
cancellations between them and that will
make this achievable okay hard problem
very nice open problem
foreign
this is all for uh uniform distributions
right yeah because is there anything at
all like going for more General like
even some of these cases like uh Organic
Solutions but the distribution density
is
um but in terms of the nearest
neighborhood like the expected nearest
neighbor distance so again scaling will
not be affected under the assumption
that I will explain okay because that's
a constant Factor okay
that's that's what I can say right now
if you have these tails and stuff then
that will change
hopefully the nearest neighbor listens
to something you can get a handle on and
then hopefully the translations
[Music]
because of scaling one over n power one
over d looks like 40 percent
yeah so you've mapped it in a way that
doesn't work uh I think so this if you
think about
where in what situations can I get down
close to the nearest neighborhood
discounts I mean there is going to be a
Distance on the time axis but that
doesn't contribute to our cost so at
that point the mapping doesn't work
there it keeps also don't take it too
literally like this is the closest the
Formal Connection is only this lower
part
[Music]
Supply the uniform distribution of
Supply optimal when the demand is
uniform
like what would be the optimal supply
list yeah I think that's close too I
mean even if you have Surplus like this
app yeah yeah so so actually you want to
make sure that it's well spread out you
have to have a spread so let's say I
want to make sure that my pickup
business is small so somehow the
relocation of Supply should be such that
the distribution like over some time
Horizon should be the distribution of
the relocated uh position of the driver
it should be the same as a demand
distribution after that those pickup
distances and then so that is just like
uh just to maintain the steady state now
you also want to keep a little excess
everywhere so you want to dynamically
manage and make sure that there are cars
in all neighborhoods like this is
actually important uh yeah
couldn't there be some boundary effects
in this case I'm like with other less
like speed or whatnot like yeah sure
yeah so these things are probably gonna
get washed away in the constant factors
uh if you like Tauruses you can think
about the tourists
yeah
and guys that are just sitting right now
you're matching the flux but the mp2
that's it yeah so instead you could have
a dynamic model where
you could do some kind of matching so
you wait until you have time
to remove magic well yeah so this uh
batting
if I have a badge which then sits of
only order and demand units or fuel then
the scaling results are unchanged
so your back side will have to be larger
than the number of Supply units sitting
around this by the way is not the regime
for uh for a normal idea
like maybe for uh like this right share
which now is not very popular right so
after covert but when you want to pair
customers then they might make you may
wait for longer but the regime is not
there you make people wait for so long
that the pool thickness increases enough
to change the scaling I mean that's a
lot it might change some constant Factor
yeah I can say that connects up with
some of our conversations
independent location across time
I would think yes yes
so you will need a lot of correlation
again to change the scaling but yeah if
it's there then it's a problem
foreign
[Music]
where are these results coming from okay
so this intuition uh this is how I think
about these problems and I think you can
try to get some of this even if you
missed some of the results I was telling
you so far think about the static model
or the semi-dynamic model
what we want to do is to understand
what's happening in D Dimension that
length scale L for every L starting from
the nearest neighbor distance and going
up to the uh macro distance okay so for
any l in this this interval I can look
at a unit hypercube and I can ask what
is the uh how large can the stochastic
fluctuations in the amount of demand in
there be
right and if let's say I have no excess
Supply that's stochastic fluctuation can
go against me and it might be I have
more demand than Supply here
how much more square root of n times the
volume okay some basic calculation uh
and if that's the case I need to go
outside to find enough Supply to match
all the demand inside how far outside so
that's like surface area times this
Delta uh times n this should be the
amount of excess demand that I'm
compensating for okay so I have to
compare the square root of the volume
and the surface area of this uh side
length L hypercube and this tells me how
large this Delta can have to be I call
this the barrier to matching at length
scale
so you can compute this as a function of
this D and as a function of L right and
uh this picture basically tells us
what's happening
on the x-axis I have this length scalar
the y axis I have this barrier to
matching
right in 1D the macro barrier to
matching is the most dominant one so
what do I need to do to match those in
the left half of the unit interval
that's what my my main challenge is in
2D all length scales have the same
barrier to Magic it's of the same scale
same same order so that's where these
funky logarithmic factors show up I
think the square root of log that's why
greedy fails it doesn't take into
account cancellations between different
length scales
so three and higher Dimensions the
nearest neighbor distance so the micro
length scale is the one that dominates
the hardest thing is to find the nearest
neighbor other length scales don't
bother me some of the surface area of
larger balls is large enough that I just
go a little bit more and I can find lots
of options and bigger things
this ISO parametric type of thinking is
is actually for me very helpful
okay in this type of thinking also tells
us what's the benefit of excess Supply
it kind of gets rid of the problem at
the larger length scales because it
dominates the stochastic fluctuations at
those larger length scales
okay so this this is uh the intuition
that I wanted to make sure I convey uh
in the fully Dynamic model somehow time
acts like an additional spatial
Dimension so even the 1D case acts like
the 2D case and the pictures that I
showed you and we don't have this
problem at the longer length scales
the algorithm is a is a that I have used
to prove most of these results is a
variant on greedy that I could analyze
so it consists of basically taking the
unit hypercube subdividing it uh into
Child hypercussed by cutting each side
length in half and you keep doing this
until you get down to the nearest
neighbor distance length scale
okay and then you try to match within
the same Leaf hyperview but if there is
no Supply you go up to the uh one of the
sibling hypercubes and if that doesn't
work you go up to one of the first
cousin hypercubes so so you're kind of
decomposing this way the cost across the
different length scales and in fact the
cost at each level of this this uh
hierarchy is of the same order as the
barrier to matching at that length scale
okay so that's pretty much the intuition
for the semi Dynamic model uh for the
fully Dynamic model it's a little bit
more involved
it's like the increase in the objective
to make the touchscreen like that
conversion is
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay good I'm concerned
yes I think that that sounds like what
to do so I would have to think a little
more but it sounded
foreign
okay so bottom line we we understood
where we have the case where there's
plan demand distribution the same and
the nearest neighbor distance is almost
always achievable okay so now we want to
take this and uh and move forward by the
way there are nice open problems here
which I will skip over for now but happy
to talk about these offline or maybe
tomorrow if there's room in your in your
session uh
definitely yes okay there are many open
browsers yes okay okay okay
so now we want to understand something
closer to the application and one key
difference is going to be that demand
and Supply distributions are not same
right so we will look at uh look at
application motivated models uh which
have this feature and also will allow
the match cost to not just be the
distance but maybe some power of the
distance
we will see that the power 2 comes up
naturally in one of the models and this
already basically eliminates
hierarchical greedy as a candidate
because it's matching some people at
long distances and not paying a heavy
price so now it's not going to give you
good scaling Behavior
okay so we will look at there will be
two papers that I'll Breeze through now
and both of them will be the
semi-dynamic model which I think is more
more relevant except for ride healing uh
ride hailing I think the equal
distribution thing is not too bad okay
so we we talked about why a little bit
but for other applications I think the
semi Dynamic model is probably closer to
the reality and we will be looking at P
equal to 2 it will turn out that's what
comes out naturally uh in these slightly
more applied models so first uh let's
look at a model inspired a little bit by
matching platforms it's going to have
smooth spatial distributions not the
same as each other the match value will
be the inner product
of of the demand point and the supply
point and uh we will now need to really
think about how to do the magic you
can't do it greedily it's going to give
us very poor performance
so this is inspired this is with hilun
Chan and akshat Kumar uh it's inspired
by these matching platforms so let's
think of uh lodging right so you have
listings they have some attributes let's
think of two price and distance to
downtown and let's say the customers
have sensitivities to the price and to
the distance to downturn okay each
customer has their own sensitivity let's
model the match value as the inner
product between the sensitivity vector
and the attribute vector okay if you
have put in this minus sign you want to
maximize this this inner product
and this maximizing this inner product
in a setting where I have n demand units
and N Supply units no excess Supply is
equivalent to minimizing the squared
distance
it's a simple calculation
so so we are back to minimizing distance
but now we are minimizing the squared
distance okay there's no reason demand
and Supply distributions should be the
same they even have different
interpretation so we will allow these
two to be different so just this Max
mean also when you're approximate
cleanliness
utility sure so then the square comes
out from that uh it certainly helps us
right so one of the open problems is
going to be what if it's not true and
some other power and we don't know how
to handle it well we don't feel too bad
about the inner product
okay okay
so now all of us are sleeping so one
more riddle for you uh so I have a
demand distribution which is uniform
between zero and half and I have a
supply distribution which is uniform
between half and one so what is the
optimal transport which will maximize
the expected inner product between the
demand point and the supply point
has it made
this is taking it fine and matching it
to half plus that point
now if I use a greedy algorithm and by
the way uh
sorry yes yeah
so the scale
so I'm deciding to maximize the average
product between the demand location and
the supply increase so the demand value
foreign yeah
I understand I think I was yesterday at
uh UIUC at this workshop and
want to make the post livestock and I
slept through the other half of it
you are on camera
no I mean she saw me so I think it
doesn't it worse
um okay
so this is the this is the uh the
optimal transport now if you think about
uh actual matching platform it doesn't
do the magic like Airbnb or upwork they
are trying to give each person like the
best quality recommendation just as well
they're running like Netflix right that
they can Netflix can have the same movie
watched by everybody but these guys have
a matching constraint but like the
default is they will just make
recommendations without looking at the
matching constraint so this means you
are doing a greedy man you're doing a
random uniformly random matching uh
effectively if your demand is coming in
in a uniformly random order and in this
case there's maybe a 10 Gap so it could
be a 50 Gap okay I won't claim more than
50 because I haven't checked but it can
be a pretty big gap okay
so we need to use the optimal transport
and stuff I will not cover now but uh he
loan and access have done a great job
which is there are two other key
elements that need to go into an
algorithm which can achieve
uh the right regret scaling and and the
optimal regret scaling and degrade here
is how far I fall short of the fluid
optimal transport value additively
so these two other elements there they
call it symmetricization and online Fair
allocation so this means that there are
algorithms for identical distribution is
doing a much better job than
hierarchical really it's matching
everybody to somebody close by as
opposed to I think some people are the
distance I won't go into uh what they
have done but bottom line is that they
are able to probably achieve the best
regret scaling and by the way this thing
is like a square of the nearest neighbor
distance except in the 1D case where
it's a square of that other quantity
that came on 1 by square root n so
editing basically the same type of
result
so it again the same other caveat said
uh anupam brought up we are not able to
do this analysis for p naught equal to
the ninth problem uh we are not we don't
know even algorithmically how to proceed
with an exercise Supply and we need to
spare matching type of thing nice
problem okay I don't even know how to
approach it I don't even have a
heuristic and then
for these platforms they need to
decentralize the solution they need to
know how to make recommendations they
don't control the matching they could be
incentive issues there could be other
kinds of issues maybe the customers have
Choice probabilities
uh very nice I think question or set of
questions
talk a little bit about Revenue
management so this is work with for my
Best Buys and access Kumar
so this actually is also it can be
viewed as a semi Dynamic uh model uh
question but now in in Revenue
management right it's as though your
supply distribution is atomic
okay and we're going to see what if your
demand distribution is uh is smooth like
the kind of distribution we looked at so
far and what if it's lumpy okay and and
we are going to come up with a new
algorithmic inside to solve uh the
problem and the demand distribution is
also Lumpy
so so uh okay this is we this is the
multi-secretory problem okay so I have a
sequence of n secretaries with abilities
drawn from some distribution F and uh
each time I have to make an irrevocable
higher or not decision and I have a
capacity of B secretaries I can hire I
want to get the largest sum of abilities
right in the people that I hire
okay so the standard this is a it's a
revenue management problem the standard
policy is certainty equivalent with
resolving so this is a special case of
optimal transport but you recomputed
after each arrival you see how much
budget is remaining how many people are
going to come in you recompute the
threshold so there's some threshold
uh
so this
this is known distribution known
distribution yes known distribution
okay so this is uh this is going to give
some constant or logarithmic uh regrets
both for Atomic distribution as well as
for smooth distribution like uniform
zero one but the one of the first things
we show is that if you have a continuous
distribution but with a gap like this
this regret of this policy can be square
root n so even optimal transport is
resolving optimal transport is not
enough
it was enough if you had a smooth
distribution of demand but only the
supply was lumpy it had atoms but not
enough when both sides are lumpy and we
introduce a principle we call
conservativeness with respect to gaps
here which basically says that if my
threshold is close to the Gap from the
optimal transport
and I I compute that there's a risk that
I will hire some low value secretaries
and in future I will have to turn down
some high value secretaries let me avoid
this risk let me just use the Gap itself
as a threshold let me reject low value
secretaries as long as this risk
persists
so this is important and we are able to
get the optimal regret scaling in
various uh under under various sets of
assumptions
that uh was what I wanted to say uh
there are some open problems here as
well most importantly the
multi-dimensional version of this
multi-secretory is a one-dimensional
problem uh an axis has been working hard
on you maybe this is uh this warrants
more than one paper though it's a hard
problem
okay so just to just to wrap up now so
we uh we've done these scaling
characterizations this is Regret we are
able to bring it down to the nearest
neighbor distance in uh all except that
one aberrant case we gave algorithmic
insights and this actually there's a
sort of nice high level picture forming
as well if you have different
distributions of demand and Supply you
cannot use greedy you need to use the
optimal transport if both of them are
smooth you can use a static optimal
transport if it's like Revenue
management where the supply distribution
is atomic right but the demand
distribution is smooth you can use a
dynamic optimal transport the resolving
certainty equivalent policy if both
sides are lumpy you have to use an
additional risk conservativeness with
respect to gaps type of thing uh that we
found
lots and lots of open problems of both
theoretical as well as applied interest
okay you survived end of the day
[Applause]
you mentioned about
the other thing I can think of is just
distance between two distances
to it's a constant factor for any
which is
yeah yeah so we don't care about the
concept s dependence on the uh I mean I
do but there was one of my open problems
so I think uh I think that you should be
able to get down to within one plus
little row of one of the nearest Simple
systems in high dimension
okay because you just need a little more
that shell has so much volume it should
be enough so nice
and that is what you meant by the sharp
characteristics
yeah yeah okay
so the static thing is able to analyze
it the Dynamics I don't think he was
either
I got much of the inspiration from this
was like various email conversations
earlier